knock knock let the devil win
we're gonna watch today from new rock
stars
the venom
let there be carnage easter eggs and
break down i caught some while watching
it let's see if voss can keep up with my
knowledge dude it's gonna be a challenge
gonna do a spoiler talk tomorrow people
keep a look out
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of venom
let there be carnage a film that further
ensnares eddie brock in stickier love
affairs that use way too much tongue i'm
not just talking about carnage oh
spoiler warning for the film's
post-credits scene venom's now getting
peter parker in on that action and i'm
uncomfortable with it i'm gonna break
down all of the easter eggs and
interesting filmmaking details that you
might have missed in this film we opened
on the saint estes reform school in 1996
based on the saint estes home for boys
in the marvel comics the orphanage where
cletus cassidy lived as a kid and
allegedly burned down before becoming
the venom symbiote offshoot carnage and
first meeting spider-man in the ruins of
this building now in 1996 woody
harrelson was the 35 year old star of
puppet and the people vs larry flint so
here playing young cletus is actor jack
bendera but they still had woody
harrelson voice the character to open
the film with harrelson's iconic soft
indoor voice i honestly thought that was
really distracting
so obviously and i'm also at a point too
where i'm like you could have de-aged
him couldn't you yeah at this point i
thought that's like their whole thing is
like guys we d aged another one maybe
not sony's yeah but now they put that
money elsewhere venom is in the mcu they
could have borrowed some of that
de-aging money it's like how josh radner
evolves into bob saget before we reveal
the character as an unhinged psychopath
all to ground cletus's priorities as his
romantic love for francis barrison aka
shriek the marvel villain who teams up
with carnage in the maximum carnage
storyline in the comics her character is
capable of releasing these powerful
sonic blasts which francis describes as
saying my mutations are advancing
previously the word was somewhat avoided
at least in the mcu films but now that
marvel studios owns the x-men ip and
this movie with its post-credits scene
is linked with the mcu is just another
side of how this is all connected to a
multiverse of marvel characters where
mutants can now exist you know what i
gotta add is that even though i i feel
like ultimately now my harris was
underutilized i still do think that what
they conceived in terms of her
relationship with cletus cassidy was
much stronger than how was it for
maximum carter's where clearly this
movie is borrowing from and that they
like they meet during carnage's breakout
and she's they're all just like yeah i
just like to kill i like just violence
and she's like into rock bands and she's
like a former groupie and all that i
like the fact that they included
something that was a much more personal
history to ground it a bit more in terms
of making having to make more sense why
he's so motivated by having to rescue
her francis gets taken away escorted by
the young cop p mulligan later detective
mulligan whom she deafens in one ear as
he shoots her in the eye to create her
eye scar from the comics and she's taken
to the ravencroft institute the
superhero prison laboratory from the
marvel comics the east coast version of
which showed up in the amazing
spider-man 2 in 2014. she's overseen by
dr pazzo the name of a ravencroft doctor
whom carnage takes captive in the venom
carnage unleash series tom hardy returns
to eddie brock and the voice of venom
last seen in the 2018 film transitioning
from a star tv investigator to prince
journalist interviewing serial killer
cletus cassidy and san quentin and now
we know his employer is the daily bugle
west coast edition since it is
headquartered in new york and it has the
same masthead as the version of the
daily bugle from the sam raimi
spider-man trilogy despite those movies
having their own eddie brock played by
topher grace but with the multiversal
implications of this movie's
post-credits scene those paradoxes
either don't really matter or are about
to matter a whole lot what i've heard
one theory is that venom might because
of this like paradoxical collision might
have absorbed some of the
memories
oh yeah yeah finally he's gonna get
justice for tony that's right justice
for topher knock knock the topher in
eddie and venom feud with detective
mulligan whom venom nearly bites head
off of actually later mulligan's tussle
with carnage and shriek leaves his eyes
glowing setting him up as the future
symbiote toxin as mulligan becomes in
the comics venom begs eddie to play
vigilante saying we should be out there
protecting the city lethally setting up
their reunion by the end of this movie
as the lethal protector nodding of
course the venom lethal protector
storyline that both this movie and its
predecessor are inspired by in which
eddie brock works in san francisco and
teams up with spider-man as this movie's
closed moments hint will happen at some
point in the films i really hope that
when they do team up it's after they've
had a rivalry established because yes
they've had to team up before to fight
common foes so it makes sense to me that
eventually they would team up they
haven't portrayed venom at all to be a
villain yet so maybe it'll just be like
a battle of ideologies because like
venom
likes to kill wear spider-man no no kill
and clearly eddie will at certain points
budge on that no eating people rule do
you bleed
you will
you will
so bad eddie interviews cletus again who
tells him to print this cryptic quote
the distant cathedral is all i see that
fractured angel the other part of me
yeah this movie shows eddie's
investigative journalism into the mind
of cletus cassidy as a kinda goony style
treasure hunt with rhyming clues and
using the shape of a coastline as x
marks the spot and all this comes from
venom's photographic memory of the
carvings in cletus's prison cell which
venom redraws for eddie a way of showing
how venom's symbiote mind is far more
advanced than eddie's human memory is he
really needs him to be able to function
in the wall
teddy bear his stick for yourself
torturing an animal in a cage it looks
like a figure holding a severed head the
words the phoenix will rise cassidy's
stick together with his hands up as a
gun fires a bullet that loops over his
head probably his own joke that the cops
wanted references the case on all of his
murders and then this quote thus
strangely are our souls constructed and
by slight ligaments are we bound to
prosperity and ruin this is a quote from
mary shelley's frankenstein in which dr
victor frankenstein considers morality a
tight wire act as he stitches together
the body parts of dead criminals into a
reanimated corpse that goes on to
consider itself above the morality of
mankind reflecting cletus's arc in this
movie as a condemned criminal about to
be a corpse becoming a sort of
resurrected supernatural monster with a
hell of an ego and then on the other
wall of the cell there's clevis himself
in a cage above a tombstone that says
hell for vanished children similar to
the sign outside saint estes that's
mark's home for unwanted children and
then there's a carving of the degree
that eddie later looks at on the sketch
form and then later finds on these
grounds with the different quotes
the stripe was given between the
suffering this is a line from a poem
called prometheus from 1816 by english
poet lord byron which praises the old
byron from greek mythology who stole
fire from the gods and gave it to the
mortals which is also a reflection of
cletus's journey as a deceitful mortal
who steals the power that came really if
you think about it from the heavens and
if he is like prometheus he can come
back from the dead right always dying
always resurrecting venom versus venom
versus carnage there we go every year
and i gotta say too that made me really
appreciate a lot more of the attention
to detail there in the room because even
that little animation there of humanoid
drawing kind of looked like the figures
that animated figure that comes up later
in the movie when eddie brock was
reading his letter yeah that's cool it's
cool attention to detail montage so the
sketches take them to rodeo beach in
marin county it's two miles north of the
golden gate bridge it's known for unique
rock formations on the coastline and
here they find more of cletus's victims
causing the governor to lift
california's moratorium on the death
penalty moratorium that our governor
gavin newsom ordered in 2019 and this
movie hints the governor did this to
boost his poll numbers maybe a nod to
the recent recall effort that newsom was
able to survive that i had to spend all
summer talking about to older relatives
in other parts of the country who were
like excited it might happen because
they all weirdly hate california but
joke's on them it rules here and we love
our rich history of the mysterio killers
and it turns out executing them
i don't think it is because this movie
was shot before that i want to say it
would have been at least conceived or in
the writing phase or in production
unless you know they just added that
line in really quick to be topical say
march 2019 is when he did it oh never
mind this is a politically deep movie
this movie just got woke all the time oh
no they said it wasn't woke you that
tyro magnus clip
as mulligan reacts to this news in the
daily bugle in his office there's a
booking photo for e larson a nod to eric
larson comic book artist and writer from
the 90s spider-man era who went on to
co-found image comics eddie's apartment
is a mess it's covered in m m's for
venom's love of eminem because
chocolate contains xenoelecthylamine
that they say is also in human brains
suggesting i guess that chocolate is
venom's anti-drug replacement for eating
human brains but in actuality
phenylethylamine when consumed causes
the brain to release other chemicals so
it's not in the brain itself but i just
think eddie might have told venom this
in order to get him to stop eating
people eddie also tried to use chickens
but venom named two of them sonny and
cher after the singing duo and then he's
also got a tire chew toy that he named
snooki now when venom overtakes eddie
their new height punches a hole in the
ceiling and i like how you can actually
see past ceiling holes from when this
has happened previously they returned to
the bodega of mrs chen from the first
movie where venom just on the rack a
publication bearing the likeness of stan
lee it even names him on the cover
calling back stan's cameo as a dog
walker in the previous film and
confirming that stan was just plain
himself venom takes the reigns and stops
a mugging leading eddie dangling while
he gets a call from ann who tells him
that she needed some space after the
alien incident before referring to when
she turned into she venom in the 2018
film and she meets eddie in their old
favorite restaurant but now what was
previously a blue background lighting is
red reflecting carnage's growing
influence in eddie's life you know what
i didn't notice until watching footage
from this movie yesterday what's that
she doesn't have the wig from the prior
movie
all the attention went to cletus cassidy
not getting his sideshow bob wig back
but now it's her too and i'm like no
wonder she looks kind of normal in this
one
hey sometimes you gotta know when to
change up the wig and shows eddie the
new engagement ring she got from dan
which eddie comments is so much bigger
than the one i got you and when you
actually compare the two side by side
dan got the more expensive flourish of a
double halo around the center stone so
truly it's just a cosmetically nicer i
love that you took the diamond
let's pull the whole juice off from the
1937 gershwin musical shall we take a
great movie song about a couple movies
work past her differences and venom
includes with all the food a whole bunch
of painkillers which you'll notice eddie
just keeps lying around because
obviously he needs him venom also drops
in the mail including cletus's postcard
with its tiny tiny writing and venom
asks eddie if he's pen pals with an ant
something that eddie might now be able
to do with ant-man now that they're in
the same universe and both living in san
francisco but cletus wrote this letter
and it looks like in his own blood
saying every hero has an origin story as
he crushes a spider of course a meta
joke about how this isn't a spider-man
origin story actually venom and
carnage's origins in these movies have
been completely spider-less and only
after carnage's death does spider-man
enter the picture we learn all about his
past as a child pushing his grandmother
down a flight of stairs as he does in
the comics but also executing his mother
with a hair dryer during a bath and his
father abusing him and so eddie visits
cletus during this
calls him a cancer and venom lashes out
allowing cletus to bite eddie on the
hand actually the same way peter parker
got his powers accepted
with the fighter getting the power
through that correlation
here as the blood wiggles on his finger
he slurps it all up actually in the
comics cletus and eddie share a prison
cell and there an offshoot of the venom
symbiote latches onto cletus turning him
into carnage that's why in this film the
carnage symbiote considers itself
venom's offspring calling him father
that was something that was kind of
missing for me here was i didn't quite
get why carnage doesn't like venom like
wants to kill him i don't know if you
guys can fill it in for me at least in
the comic cletus wants to kill eddie
brock and then moments before the venom
symbiote latches back onto eddie and
then you know blah blah blah he becomes
carnage but then his car is about to
break out venom and spider-man team
together to stop him you know so
basically the chance for freedom and
escapism venom and spider-man put an end
to it so it makes sense why carter is
like damn you yeah you know
uh but here i'm like what does carnage
hate him so much
why wouldn't carter be like hey we
should team up at least initially before
venom's like no sorry man because
carnage uh clearly seems to have a more
of a dominant overpowering personality
as opposed to trying to look for
camaraderie well yeah and he's at least
making that connection or calling him
father so you would think that i don't
know is that just a hundred percent
facetious yeah i also kind of thought
that the movie could not that i don't
even really remember how it happens in
the comic or if they even try to explain
it the movie i thought could have at
least made an attempt to fill in some
reasoning for why the one bite of eddie
would lead to cartage being like just as
maximum powerful yeah yeah what changed
in that one transfer that isn't gonna
affect eddie because it seems like
eddie's blood is the key and why
wouldn't he be as powerful yeah like
what venom was clearly intimidated and
scared from him you know yeah eddie and
venom fight but i'm the only person that
took you in when your friends kicked you
off the planet ming monk cause you are a
reject yeah eddie says planet ming mong
which in reality venom's home planet is
klyntar which is also the name of his
species vitum actually hints that he's
ready to share his hive mind with eddie
in the post credit scene but the
multiverse collision interrupts it or
might have caused it i go into that in
our post credit scene breakdown
after andy circus broke this fight scene
down for vanity fair describing how they
upgraded venom's appearance from the
2018 film to add some lip texturing
around venom's wide jaw and eyebrow
brushes all in order to give venom's
face a more expressive quality now
circus obviously draws upon his own
extensive background and the
relationship between physical
performance and vfx animation from when
he brought to life gollum and snoke and
caesar for the planet of the apes
trilogy which are an amazing group of
films there you should check them out i
can't uh overstate this enough i
actually do really think that the mocap
for this was so much better venom felt
like a real person to me like venom not
eddie brock i'm talking about venom like
i felt like that was a real character
alive who i associated and not not just
observing not being aware that tom
hardy's doing the voice or the mocap i
was just into who the character was and
i was very and dear to him yeah you feel
like he's there on screen and circus
also revealed that tom hardy
pre-recorded all of venom's dialogue and
then would play it back in his ear so
that he could have the real argument
with venom's voice all going on in his
head if you look closely you can
actually see the earbud tucked way in in
his ear there also when venom breaks
eddie's nose and fixes it just so we can
break it again you can see where venom
resets that broken nose and the bruising
fades away right before he punches him
again this is just like how venom fixed
eddie's broken bones after the
motorcycle crash in the previous film
now on the night of his execution cletus
quotes shakespeare's macbeth
it's from act four scene one the second
half of a couplet spoken by the second
witch foretelling the arrival of the
morally corrupt macbeth actually the
full couplet is by the pricking of my
thumb something wicked this way comes
when you think about it cletus acquired
his powers bye bye
the poetry throughout the movie is
pretty sweet design is sickening with
pock marks on his tongue to make him
look all decaying also in general a more
slender build compared to venom an ooze
dripping off his tendrils he's got a
raptor like roar
and then a splash of black on his face
which i think is to link him to his
parents symbiote venom he attacks the
cell block using tendrils to stab and
hurl guards around he flinches one guard
and then he forms a big cyclone and when
they try to shoot him carnage opens a
hole in his chest to let the bullet sail
through meaning that for now at least he
and cletus do have a functioning
symbiosis their flesh is infused one in
the same pleiades dances out of san
quentin and sings and i'll walk out a
wiser stronger man mr warden you taste
just like ham which is a parody of
johnny cash's song san quentin named
after this prison and which the normal
lyric is and i'll walk out a wiser
weaker man mr congressman you can't
understand i believe that seen in the
movie though what he was walking out was
nighttime yeah it looked like it
dude what's going on what's going on
boss what's up man wow what's up using
the old promo materials bro coming for
you the old promo materials why don't
you use the bootleg try not to get
de-monetized and just copyright striked
even though they did that all for shang
chi and the post criticism i know i'm
marvel at how they're able to get away
with some of these shots they show
you'll notice during this whole final
act of the film eddie wears the detroit
lions jacket over a mumford phys ed
shirt which is an onto another famous
eddie eddie murphy in beverly hills cop
too venom attends a rave with a cameo by
rapper little sims which becomes
essentially venom's coming out party he
even says in his speech that he has come
out of the eddie closet okay guys get
ready trigger warning i'm gonna touch on
something oh i don't think it's that big
a deal if venom and eddie do have this
romantic codependent bond with each
other
because
it feels like when you read some [ __ ] in
the comics you're like
these two talk like lovers too each like
their relationships and the way they
fight is that of of like it sounds like
a lover's intimacy
these people know each other in each
other's hands they know each themselves
and each other intimately and yeah they
argue on this level because there's no
other level yeah yeah i'm not saying
they're gonna like do sexual stuff with
each other but who knows but no it's
yeah it's a lot closer and more familiar
than you know friends he could take over
anne's body that's that eddie does and
well he could take both of them
at the same time
turn over
i from tower eddie
i used to be on top
[Laughter]
carnage tendrils to hack the internet
which is an odd to carnage infamously
snaking into a computer and using the
internet to invade the homes of his prey
in the comics one of the really crazy
things that he does that seemed actually
i'm glad it's a nod but it made no sense
to me
he's alien and computers are sci-fi and
aliens are sci-fi so the internet it's
as crazy as this movie is for some
reason that's the only scene where i've
got pulled out going how's that possible
what
that wouldn't happen
you would just break that computer and
then back at the ravencroft institute
there is another inmate there named
siegfried i looked it up there's not a
prominent siegfried in the marvel comics
other than a kind of obscure antagonist
to dum-dum dugan in the old search and
fury comics i don't think this is him
just kind of a missed opportunity like
he could have thrown a rhino in there
you know but carnage breaks into
shriek's confinement and uses his
tendrils to
purcell crushes it to bring them into an
embrace and they escape in this red
conversion she gets no cuts
natural born killer vibes here meanwhile
she's not even faced by his trans story
a drunk partier and oozes out of them
and later overtaking his chin base to
ann and dan and the funniest scene in
the film shriek tries to find eddie at
his place and sees a photo of anne and
then goes after her and dan all so that
they can have guests to their red
wedding and at one point and once again
becomes she venom to break eddie out of
custody and the wedding goes down in
grace cathedral similar to carnage's
church setting in the final level of the
maximum carnage video game how come when
venom takes over other people throughout
this movie he takes the venom shape we
all know but when he takes over and it's
all feminine and slender and boobs why
wasn't mrs chen sexy at least well like
you remember those other people like
when you go to the club is that an
eddie's body that's true but some of
those are dudes so it makes sense
and venom sees carnage for the first
time oh [ __ ] that is a red one now don't
be too hung up on the color here it's
not like there's a yoshi color coding
system the symbiote hierarchy venom is
just recognizing that carnage is more
intertwined with cletus's actual blood
which freaks him out because he's been
having some insecurities about his own
level of symbolism oh okay that makes
more sense
that they brought there to officiate the
wedding saying power up using them to
grow so i guess clergy is symbiote
superfood at one point carnage looms
over venom framed in the stained glass
which the director called an homage to
the leonardo da vinci vitruvian man's
sketch which davinci drew to just
intelligent design and the ratios of
human anatomical structures the fact
that carnage is crudely recreating this
is just another example of his let there
be carnage ego he considers himself a
god embarking upon his own genesis the
dawn of a new era but the battle turns
when carnage tries to kill shriek
because he hates her sonic blasts he's
pissed off that she cares about anne's
life and that turns cletus against
carnage and proving to venom that they
do not have the true symbiosis that he
thought they did at one point ann falls
and she's framed in venom's eye very
similar to the shot of spider-man's
loved ones falling in his eyes mary jane
in the first rainy film and gwen stacy
in the maze in spider-man 2 shriek gets
back at carnage by blasting the bell
detaching everybody's symbiotes and
collapsing the tower as well as the bell
entry and venom's able to gobble up
carnage actually just as he does at one
point in the comics and he bites off
clayton's head dropping this
unfortunately rated pg-13 movies one
f-box in the aftermath eddie talks about
cervantes don quixote quoting facts are
the enemy of truth lamenting that
despite he and venom aspiring to be
lethal protectors and factually serving
the public good by disposing carnage the
truth that society will only be able to
see are them as a monster and that
distinction between facts and truth gets
further warped in the film's ending
after a great closing shot showing the
two runaways on a mexican beach finally
giving venom that sand in his toes and
wind in his hair that he had always
wanted a post credit scene where venom
offers to open eddie's mind to the
symbiote hive mind a hint that we might
actually meet the klyntar society in
venom 3 but then these two are suddenly
transported to another reality that of
the mcu with venom reacting to jonah
jameson's report on peter parker
probably or maybe the mcu got
transformed into sodium that's right
it's all back in sony baby where it
belongs officially part of the mcu now i
did break down this scene and its
implications to no way home and the
whole mcu multiverse going forward all
in another video but i love that this
film ends in this place of facts versus
truth because eddie brock and peter
parker now have this in common as two
misunderstood vigilantes battling that
false truth of the world seeing them as
psychopaths i think it gives them a
common cause to fight as fellow lethal
protectors in a world where reality
cannot be believed however we must
remember that cervantes don quixote ends
with them burning the books because
kyoto's fantasies are destructive
inferior to the real world ultimately i
remember that
all those times i read don quixote
reject the allure of an impossible dream
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at ea boss fall and subscribe to
new rockstars for breakdowns of
everything you love thank you for
watching bye you know what they get me
excited though is that we might finally
get a venom who can
who can thwhip that's right they might
actually get the venom symbol
called chest plated dude
this is what eddie i hope they stand in
front of the mirror for like a whole
minute of comedy is what these movies
like to do yeah yeah
and then ann can walk in and he's like
what i finally understand and yeah this
is what a symbiotic man really means
all right guys thanks for being here
keep a lookout for spoiler talk this is
fun man i mean that did make me
appreciate the movie a lot more oh yeah
yeah boss always succeeds at that you
manipulate her
subscribe to them uh check us out on
more videos i know how to outro it's
done
[Music]
you